there's a topic of god that comes up all
the time for me people always ask me so
what's your religious belief i'm like no
you don't have any religious belief do
you believe this ritual i'm like well i
maybe it could be out there maybe it's
not that you don't think about it i'm
like no
that is for all the deep talk we've done
today one thing i literally never take a
second to think about is the existence
of god
i don't even ponder it never crosses my
mind till someone asks me it then i'm
like i don't really care and i move on
and i never think about it again
and
the reason why is because i'm like
i don't know i have no way of confirming
and it doesn't matter
the other day i'm going to be out here
i'm going to try to do right by the
people around me
if god does exist and hopefully he
accepts me knowing like i try to do or
she whatever they god you know whatever
pronoun they prefer okay
accepts me i haven't done what i've done
uh i shoot god gotta be gender neutral
right
gotta be gotta be
uh
so yeah so it's like
i don't
know to me
and i find folks think about it so much
that's what a relation is
that that's what a religion is thinking
about it so much and then after that
there's the people that are not a
religion but still think about whether
it exists or not i'm gonna be honest
with you i think a lot of folks in a
religion don't even think about it i
think they just accept it
because
they're afraid of the unknown
so they don't think about it they accept
that reality because it's so comforting
yeah you know and look look listen
whether you believe it or not i know it
i think it's perfectly fine and i think
it's absolutely necessary for a lot of
folks i'm not even here to be like i'm
above that no it's cool
i think a lot of folks don't even think
about it they just
it's got to be real and they stop there
they don't question it my experience
with folks who are hyper leaders is they
do not question the existence of god
they accept it as a unilateral fact
yeah you're right about that
they're at the beginning of the
dunning-kruger
nah because for them it's not a
progression
right it's an ultimate truth but in a
sense like they i feel like
they haven't thought deeply past that at
all like that's the further down the
curve or whatever yeah yeah that's one
thing i've never what about you guys you
think about the exists
the more i think about it the less i
think it's it exists
really
and now i talk to god ironically knowing
you don't exist
yeah sure dude that was you all right
and not just a random lightning all
right hmm what about you
i think uh i have a scientific view of
it but a lot of people who say that are
like oh i'm an atheist because there's
no proof yeah but i don't think that's a
very like
scientific way of actually thinking
about it like if you have an experiment
where you're trying to prove something
in science and you can't find a
conclusion
then it's inconclusive yeah it's not one
way or the other but i think about it
similarly to you i think where i'm like
i do think about it though i wouldn't
say i think about it all the time but i
don't know and i'm fine with that
there's no there's no evidence
yeah
but for me that the fact that there's no
evidence doesn't prove without a doubt
that there is nothing or it doesn't
exist it just it's inconclusive
that's it i like that i like that
even though i don't think about god's
existence ever i do love
thinking about like religious edicts and
i love thinking about them in more
abstract sense and really believing that
they're real so whenever people talk
about like angels and devils
i don't think about them
in literal senses i think about them in
the abstract sense and i feel like
they're real
i feel like there's people
in the world that i think you can divide
that way
or even the idea of hell in heaven i
feel like in a metaphorical sense it
could be like places that we visit in
our minds and in our life
you know i don't think about it like if
you die you're going to be sent to hell
fire and suffer for eternity for some
people like even if like imagine if your
life on earth is the only reality that
you have
for some people
they could certainly define their life
as hell
yeah
if you heard their life story and how it
started and how it ends and what it was
like throughout the whole point like
that sounds like hell to me
and so sometimes i like thinking of um
you know past stories being passed
through the bible or
certain concepts
and i know people love to take them as
literal places or literal meanings but i
think if you think about them more
abstractly in terms of the human
condition i think they're fascinating
because they can really apply it's kind
of like
mythology it literally obviously nobody
if
greek
nobody is a hydra there's no hydras
didn't exist there was no [ __ ]
monster that came out with all these
heads
but if you think about it sometimes you
do confront problems in life where
you know you cut one issue down and then
another one pops up and it's just like
this issue seems never ending every time
i feel it
a hydra could be a manifestation of
those kind of problems
you know what i'm saying or even the
story of icarus the boy like
all those stories were written in a way
that there was like a very strong moral
in terms of like archetypes the person
who's too ambitious for their own good
and flow too close to the sun
we can think of people that we know in
that sense and so sometimes i i take a
fascination with a religion and that so
that's like the lessons that it passes
down uh i think stories do a great job
of that or concepts do a great job of
like metaphorically illustrating aspects
of the human condition um so i think
that's the stuff that i think about more
than anything but as far as like the
existing god itself it's like you know i
don't think i'll ever get an answer so i
don't know for me it's just
if he's there
to be to me this is what i think about
it
whether it's true or not has literally
zero meaning in my life so i don't think
about it
it
you know what i'm saying
let's see why i could confirm
jesus of nazareth was a white man blond
hair blue eyes lived here now he's up
there whatever
okay and he hates you for fornicating
okay yes
tell me i'm like
i try to rap by people you gave me the
ability to do all this stuff if i'm not
supposed to do it well
i guess i'm going to hell it is with
this
accepted
i accept it
yeah i mean like i'm not going to start
acting funny and start acting crazy
because now i confirmed it like i don't
i'm not going to start acting all
different you know what i mean
because that sounds fake now i'm just
like i'm not doing this thing that i
would do just because i want to no you
would do this [ __ ] out of fear
that would be the only thing that would
motivate you god is the ultimate coyote
[Music]
hey to some people that's definitely
true yeah absolutely that's facts that's
what you're calling he's a god-fearing
man that's a compliment you know he's
yeah and i'm like okay you're afraid